Good morning Hank, it's Monday
Hank it's no secret that the three most viewed videos on the vlogbrothers channel
feature, in order, giraffe sex, giraffe sex, and giraffe sex.
And, yet, Hank, it recently occurred to me that in spite of all of this,
we have never actually made a video about...
Giraffe sex.
A shortcoming I intend to rectify today.
So, Hank, not to call you out, but the other day
on twitter, you tweeted an image that you designed.
Now, Hank, let's put aside the question of why you,
a busy professional, spend your free time coming up with
cute images of giraffe love, THIS would make a great t-shirt, and so
it IS a great t-shirt.
Hank, nerdfighters, that shirt is available for preorder now at dftba.com
link in the dooblydoo!
But anyway, Hank, you illustration of giraffe love may be adorable
but it completely belies the truth about giraffe mating
which is that it is profoundly
...
non-romantic.
To begin with, Hank, giraffes are extremely promiscuous
and when I say "extremely promiscuous"
I mean they rarely mate with the same person twice
In fact they don't mate with people at all,
they mate with giraffes.
Although that reminds me of a Yahoo answers question that I wanted to read to you
"Are male giraffes gay homosexual? I heard that they were
and if they are, would they be interested in male humans?
My friend was asking and I said I would find out for him."
Hank, pardon me for a moment, I need to use the desk really quickly.
Uuuuuggghhh! Headdesk!
Ohhhhhh, the internet, what disturbing question won't you ask?
Well, Hank, to answer that question on behalf of someone's non-existent friend
almost all male giraffes are bisexual.
In fact, researchers believe that 90% of total giraffe sex
is male giraffes having sex with male giraffes
and that 1% of total giraffe sex is females having sex with females.
Meaning that just about 9% of giraffe sex is heterosexual.
And that's really no wonder, Hank, because their heterosexual sex is...
gwebechabah
So, Hank, I present to you the majestic giraffe.
Stop looking at me that way, I know your secrets.
Giraffe mating involves a process called "flaymen"
or possibly "flehmen"
I don't know how to pronounce it and I don't want to learn.
Basically, male giraffes don't really like hooking up with female giraffes
unless they're ovulating, so to find out if they're ovulating
they use their faces to smack
the female giraffes in the bottom,
which causes the female giraffes to pee.
If they happen to like the male giraffe they'll pee a bunch.
And then the male giraffe drinks the pee to find out if it tastes like it's time to party.
Hank I will remind you I am not the pervert here
I am just reporting the facts.
He's the pervert!
Then, if the pee smells right and the lady's still into it,
there's a courtship process which mostly involves
the male giraffe trying to hump the female giraffe
and the female giraffe running away.
Until finally, coitus occurs, lasting up to
...
several seconds.
Then, the mommy giraffes are pregnant for
Four. Hundred. Freaking. Days!
No wonder they try to run away.
And the male giraffe just goes on his merry way,
hooking up with dudes, and...
...smackin'...
...pee outta girls.
...
I wish I were making this up.
So anyway, Hank, the long and short of it is
that the animal kingdom is rarely as romantic as we'd like it to be.
But there is one super cute thing about giraffes,
as seen in your image, they neck a lot.
And for a long time, biologists thought this was a way of fighting
but it turns out that while it is sometimes a way of fighting,
it's also kind of a way of hugging :).
So the shirt isn't a "lie" it's just an oversimplification
Like, some day when Henry asks me,
"How is it that baby giraffes come into the world?"
I will put on the shirt, and I will say,
"Henry, this shirt was designed by your uncle, Hank
to answer that very question."
As this helpful diagram shows, as giraffes neck,
there's a heart that forms in the space between their necks
and that heart,
*whisper* is a baby giraffe!
Thus ends our introduction to giraffe mating habits
There's a link to Hank's t-shirt in the dooblydoo
Hank, thank you for designing that, I always forget that
you're so... talented.
I know that sounds stupid but every time I see something you've designed
I always think, "wow, Hank is pretty...
...you know...
...good at stuff."
That's about as close as brothers get to complimenting each other
Hank, I'll see you on Wednesday!